have you ever used a translation app to
negotiate pricing with a stripper who
didn't speak english
[Applause]
that's a [ __ ] home run
what do you mean you want dog you
brought dog
to a dog
what what nationality was she or where
is she from
cuba
and you couldn't even get like trace dog
dolores out or nothing you couldn't you
couldn't be like me gusta
anything
what was it what was it what were you
negotiating in fact i have a feeling it
wasn't a land deal yeah
some real estate property she had yeah
i'm telling you i get you a better
interest rate right now he was asking he
was asking his buddies how do you say
hand job in spanish someone tell me
how do you say only got 40 in spanish
you [ __ ] scumbag yeah
my credit card's in the car i swear
el credit carl in el coche
[Laughter]
my dick is no hardo i'm sorry i can't do
it
i was doing el no's beers
[Laughter]
dude that question's crazy what the [ __ ]
but we must know how did this play out
what were you exactly negotiating
well that's sex right there okay fair
enough i don't want to trap you too much
fair enough we'll leave it there
don't incriminate him give it up for
thomas kyle and kyle oh
[ __ ]
man
[Applause]
dude that's crazy
oh i love it uh where's john l at
okay
i guess the leads are sitting in over
there huh
thank you man i don't know are you a
john l
okay trapping young lad i must say
[ __ ] look or give the kid a round of
applause
what's the scoop who are you here with
craig
oh congratulations there you go get get
that taquitos tequila and soda out of
her hand
fiance and then another couple
lovely friends nice this guy's drinking
a martini that's pretty [ __ ] classy
and a brave sack yeah it's real classy i
like it
he for sure has camo underwear on too
chipper jones socks on [ __ ] drinking
a martini
i like it they're my favorite too dirty
martinis extra daddy what do you do
vodka
yeah this guy's got a problem
well good luck with the pregnancy young
lady
we're gonna name jim bean
his question is am i garbage for
drinking 99 long island iced teas from
kroger
wait a minute that seems like it plays
here
did you mean arizona iced teas because
they're 99 cents
it was a long i you know he's talking
about regular ic you're talking about
the alcoholic beverage long island iced
tea you're selling long island iced teas
down here for 99 cents i'm moving that's
it i'm coming down
get the pine needles in the front yard
i'm [ __ ] moving in
holy [ __ ]
he's been talking about pine needles in
the front yard all day
we were out we were out front of the
hotel smoking a sick he's like man down
here they put pine needles in a front
yard
i'm like you live in a one bedroom in
astoria shut up
i worked as a summer as a landscaper in
north carolina and that's where i
learned that they use that down here
instead of mulch yeah don't don't leave
out of the side of the story where you
said that was also the first time you
smoke cracks no
that's true
i don't even know if there really was
pine needles
giving little kids for all i know could
have just been heroin who knows
get my landscaping advice from you
all right so what's the deal they just
sell cans of long island iced tea
are we hold on one sec are we cool is
this a move
well what was hold on a second what was
it like nine o'clock in in the morning
on the way to work
on the way here i respect that yeah what
the [ __ ]
pre-gaming with some lips on the way to
ru
garbage hey guy wants to give you a
pound right there there you go
he's gonna be selling your weed later
the guy in the tie-dye bucky shirt
hey man good to know your party
i'm the great camry out front just so
you know
i'll flick the latch when i see you
it ain't got no wheels on it but it's a
good time